murat kamera läuft so ein ganz spontaner
das video weil wir haben was herrliches
geschaffen und zwar nicht in die garage
hier mit den jungs zusammen und zwar
dieses auto nieren es ist ein traum
meiner jugend und zwar ist es nun 500
baujahr 1974 aber sieht sogar eine
kletterschule ja baujahr 1974 und auch
wir machen richtig genial ist auch wo
ich bin so glücklich darüber dass ich
mich entschlossen habe
amon card wonder zu machen und zwar ein
video wo wir jetzt die schneiden müssen
ganz ganz schnell als ein no katja und
genau stimmt ein lokal aufzumachen
auf jeden fall hier ist alles dabei als
versteckte der garage und wir haben das
auch jetzt hier eingeschoben und ich
will auch immer gerne sofort stellen und
zeigen was das besondere im auto ins
auto alex kannst du das jetzt vor
baujahr 74 du bist bei 575 ein jahr
älter als das auto okay weil ein jahr
ist es damit auch zu lachen
wir sind lustig ob er wollte ich sagen
dieses auto damit sind früher in den
siebzigerjahren ganze familie nach
rimini im urlaub befanden und rimini ist
in italien
wir hatten aber keine großen förmlichen
kosten und zwar über den brennerpass
müssten richtig und zwar über die tap
and ihnen oder serpentinen dieses jahr
könnte ihm terpentin ist ein rein
mussten will tut es sich einen song auf
jeden fall ist alles richtig cool und
ich wollte zeigen nutzt die malerei also
nicht alle also erwarten kann also im
umfang von preis gefordert
nur stärker ins auge fassen ich fahre
ich finde einzigen da noch nicht und ist
obwohl der einzige sein verfahren hat
nicht vom einzelnen
so sehen wir das den beiden noch fast es
beiden rein
die tür geht nicht so abhängig
also ihr seht gut dass es das aufgeht
sollte sich einpassen können noch hören
konnten sowohl der herren dich so und
nass und so sehr nett und zwar hier
siamak frank tom wir sind alle drin so
und das auto ach gott nicht verrenken
hier ja wenn dies also ja ich wollte ich
wollte mein handy aus meiner hosentasche
holen muss dieses jahr zwischen beide
greifen weil ich meine sonst nicht meine
hosentasche angekommen das auto fährt
übrigens 120 mann ist eben die ihren
text gerade den kopf traten zuletzt
warum weil wir überladen sind
du hast mir immer geprägt ist ja wahr
hört auf anderen seiten wir keine luft
mehr
bitte ganz langsam atmen dass die
autoschlüssel ja das ist der
autoschlüssel und zwar wir würden jetzt
mal gerne dieses auto an machen kann ist
echt lustig aus und ist auch übrigens
könnt jetzt ein paar lieder singen und
singt oder von backstreet boys
vielleicht auch machen über probiert und
nicht dein ernst mit der sehr hat sich
die haare waren wieder um das auto herum
ich hoffe er schafft es mit dem rüssel
sonst sind wir beide kaputt oder das
auto ich hoffe nur noch rückwärts andere
richtung
der tag klang der mann der hat einfach
[Musik]
zwei stunden später
nicht so gut war sehr mag ich
gleichzeitig
er wagt es nicht so ach du meine güte da
fahren sie was ich laufe da hinterher
er fährt mit
der kleine morath mit einem kleinen auto
zurück bleibt weit fährt wie immer für
sie da jetzt im vergleich zum relativ
mäßig aus ich weiß nicht so ganz aber
kommen die wieder zurück sie haben als
boygroup erfolg ich glaube schon nicht
vielleicht nicht mehr im gesang aber ich
weiß nicht wo rat und die wilden tiere
comedy gruppe als kommen sie ja als
umzugsunternehmen vor allem mit diesem
auto ja ja ja zirkusnummer jungs ihr
macht die zirkusnummer ja bist du zurück
sind vielleicht überlegen wir noch so
ein paar sachen nur aus der gegend
flitzen sehen dass und befinden vorbei
geflitzt darüber gespannt waren sowie
das standbild er wollte ja nicht
schneiden
so lange kann ich euch ja meine schuhe
zeigen
die schule habe ich von iris und dann
hatte ich kalte füße und dann habe ich
wohl sorgen darauf angezogen das weiß
ist es meine freunde
ach da waren sie weg ich dachte die
kommen zurück morath reingefahren oder
zur firma zu nachbars firma und sogar
das absichtlich gemacht
das ist die frage
ok komm wir gehen wieder zu arbeiten
nur zwei jungs